the man accused of throwing a
five-year-old off a third-floor balcony
at the Mall of America is in jail under
a two million dollar bond after his
first court appearance 24-year old men
well Rhonda is charged with attempted
premeditated first-degree murder the
little boy is still in critical
condition
Jamie yuccas is here with the disturbing
new details we learned from prosecutors
in Minneapolis Jamie good morning it's
just a horrific case Ron yeah good
morning everybody prosecutors say a
manual or onda went to the mall looking
to kill someone and he admitted to
throwing the five-year-old boy he
allegedly told police he had been coming
to the mall for years to try and talk to
women but he had been rejected and that
made him aggressive someone just fell
from the third floor to the first floor
witnesses described a chaotic scene at
the Mall of America Friday as people
rushed to perform CPR on a five-year-old
boy according to a criminal complaint
the victim's mother said they were
standing outside of the rain forest cafe
at the mall when a man now identified as
a Manuel Oh Rhonda walked very close to
them she allegedly asked him if they
were in the way and should move
prosecutors say without warning Oh
Rhonda then picked up the victim and
threw him off the third-floor balcony
the child fell around 40 feet basically
everyone standing around in complete
shock Brian Johnson saw the boy's mother
just after he was thrown she was
screaming for everyone please pray
please pray please pray for my baby
prosecutors say Oh Rhonda tried to run
but was quickly apprehended according to
the criminal complaint Oh Rhonda
admitted to police he threw the boy and
allegedly said he had formed a plan to
kill someone at the mall the day before
but it did not work out the next day he
allegedly said he set out to kill an
adult but chose the boy instead he has
three previous it contacts with the
Bloomington Police Department two of
which were at Mall of America Oh Rhonda
has had multiple run-ins with the law in
July 2015 he was arrested after
allegedly throwing things off the upper
level of the mall to the lower level in
October 2015
he was arrested at the mall again after
allegedly throwing glasses at a woman in
a restaurant when she refused to buy him
something
police say both cases were handled
through a mental health court and
resulted in convictions on Tuesday
afternoon a ronda faced attempted murder
charges for this case prosecutors say
because of the particular cruelty of the
crime they intend to pursue an
aggravated sentence and when it's
involving a young child like that it
it's pretty gut-wrenching for everybody
involved
absolutely Rhonda will be back in court
on May 14th a GoFundMe for the boy has
raised more than seven hundred thousand
dollars and on that page the boys
described as the sweetest kindest five
year old you will ever meet full of
energy and life as most five year olds
are I mean it's just so disturbing and
so upsetting it makes you wonder when
you hear about his history why he's even
walking around in the first place well
it also makes you wonder when you're in
a public space there's very little that
you can do to protect yourself in some
cases it sounds like it happened so
quickly Jamie thank you